good morning belief nation today's
message is failure is an option but fear
is not over to you James Cameron I have
young filmmakers come up to me and say
you know give me some advice for doing
this and I say don't put limitations on
yourself other people will do that for
you don't do it to yourself don't bet
against yourself and and take risks an
asset has this has this phrase that they
like failure is not an option but
failure has to be an option in art and
an exploration because it's a leap of
faith and no important endeavor that
required innovation was done without
risk you have to be willing to take
those risks so that's the thought I
would leave you with is it in whatever
you're doing
failure is an option but fear is not so
what do you think you know what I think
that's a really great message and I can
really relate to that because in life
you know you're gonna fail repeatedly
and every successful person always says
fail your way to success which pretty
much means try you're gonna fail try
gonna fail try again and then ultimately
you're gonna succeed a real failure is
one that never really tries just fails
before he even tries fear I can really
relate to because for me being in front
of the camera was a big fear like
something that I would never do cuz I'm
one behind camera guy she films videos
photos I'm never in front of the camera
so I mean with you I mean we worked on
it for like over a year's a long time
right I think over a year Evan tried to
encourage me to be in front of the
camera and I gave them every excuse and
then you're rocking it now it's nothing
snap over you cuz it haunt you whenever
you don't do something you're afraid of
doing it haunts you it's always there a
nagging thought nagging voice in the
back your head kind of saying me thanks
to you so you better just nip it in the
butt and just do it anyways feel the
fear and do it anyways and the fear
diminishes and you feel so much better
by yourself and the fear thing may
actually be your next move that thing
that you wanted to do in life that
you know where it's gonna go so as long
as you're fearful you kind of you're
blocking your good out in your life the
thing that I might add to that is we
have we have instincts we have natural
instincts when something is
uncomfortable or we're afraid of we just
naturally say no we naturally block it
out we naturally run away from it
logically it makes sense logically it
makes sense to say yes that thing that
I'm afraid of it I should go and do it
but in the moment you don't think
logically you think right you think
emotionally right you think with your
heart and you're like you want to you
want to run away from it and so I think
what helped me was training myself to
when I get uncomfortable or when I feel
a little bit of afraid to recognize it
like awareness is the first part I don't
I don't really agree with the comment
about fear is not an option I think you
will be afraid but it's feeling the fear
and doing it anyway and so if you can
recognize in the moment that I'm afraid
of this but I feel like I should go for
it I want to start challenging myself
then you get more and more comfortable
doing that
so now being in front of the camera is
not as scary as it was before it may
still be a little scary maybe it's not
scary at all but like it gets more and
more comfortable and now you're ready to
stretch your comfort zone to the next
level so getting used to feeling
uncomfortable and being okay with it and
pushing yourself to go for a little bit
more so the question of the day today is
what fear is in your way that you need
to overcome it's a deep one rich ask two
deep questions I love it leave it in the
comments below will join the discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso